Justin Timberlake yah we'd all like to
see him reunite with his fellow
Mouseketeers right but could it actually
happen I asked him about that but first
to the suite reason that JT invited et
to his music mission in Memphis Memphis
feel to be home it's great it's hot why
is it important for you to give back
well I mean listen you know I've been
lucky enough to have this platform and
this privilege and so music is the most
fun way to do it
only et was invited to see Justin
inspire the next generation of artists
in his hometown of Memphis
[Applause]
Justin led a two-day songwriting
workshop at Stax Music Academy and
partnership with the Levi's music
project that's we're gonna judge them
but you know they're all they're all so
good and we could you know we could have
the next beyoncé or John Legend in that
room not just a John Legend any type of
legend yeah John as for Justin's
introduction to the music business
I believe the shot coming up will answer
that question that was 1993 when he was
cast in the Mickey Mouse Club
that was the most influential experience
I ever had I mean we were 10 years old
we got to learn how to be on camera we
got to learn how to write dance sing act
I mean my my relationship with that is
like the ultimate fields so in separate
interviews Christina and Britney said
they would be down for a reunion and I
would definitely show it I would dick oh
we definitely need some kind of a
reunion would you ever be down sure
Justin's international success came a
few years later he first met Justin
during this time with NC and you know we
love a good throwback I have something
else I think you're gonna like you know
I just want to still be on Entertainment
Tonight ten years no what am I wearing
you look good don't focus on your lying
out of your teeth maybe I'll come host a
show this all falls apart there the
oppor still stands
ET comme host anytime what are youcome
yeah all right don't show that clip to
anybody that they're an outfit I got to
live out my awkward years in front of
all of you and it's it's uh it's it's
it's really it's haunting me what about
the et theme song do you know it is that
the John Tesh right is that is that it
[Music]
shoutout to John Tesh all right
[Music]